[Aplausos]
[Música]
en Europa hay muchos lugares donde los
temas étnicos y nacionalistas se cogen
con papel de fumar es decir que se viven
con especial intensidad prácticamente a
flor de piel sin embargo hay una región
que destaca por encima de todas las
demás como no hablamos de los balcanes
una región que en los 90 vivió en carne
propia la crueldad la sinrazón y el
horror de una despiadada guerra civil en
plena Europa en un pasado vídeo aquí en
visualpolitik que os dejamos en la
descripción os contamos muchos más
detalles sobre este conflicto Pero lo
que más nos importa en este vídeo es que
uno de sus últimos coletazos militares
fue la lucha que enfrentó a la República
Federal de yugoslavia hoy Serbia con los
separatistas kosovares de etnia albanesa
este enfrentamiento terminó en 1999 tras
la intervención de la otan con una
campaña de los medios aéreos contra la
yugoslavia de slobodan mielosevich un
tipo que por cierto terminó su vida en
una cárcel de la ciudad holandesa de la
haya mientras era juzgado por crímenes
de guerra por el tribunal Penal
Internacional para la antigua yugoslavia
un organismo creado por Naciones Unidas
para juzgar los crímenes de guerra del
conflicto yugoslavo El caso es que
aunque la guerra terminó el conflicto
étnico y político perduró y lo cierto es
que lo ha hecho hasta nuestros días
la guerra de kosovo terminó con un
tratado el de kumanobo que para
apacificar el terreno pasó a un
despliegue de tropas internacionales
pero no incluyó nada parecido a la
independencia de kosovo pese a ello
finalmente los kosovares declararon
unilateralmente su independencia y la
instauración de la República de kosovo
apenas unos pocos años después en 2008
desde entonces las relaciones entre
Serbia y kosovo son más frías que el
invierno canadiense por supuesto la
República de kosovo no está reconocida
por Serbia que sigue reclamando su plena
soberanía sobre el territorio pero para
desgracia de Belgrado si lo está por
alrededor de un centenar de Estados
miembros de las Naciones Unidas incluida
la superpotencia norteamericana los
Estados Unidos de América y también por
22 de los 27 estados de la Unión Europea
entre los que por cierto no se encuentra
España
[Música]
Pues bien esto en la práctica significa
Ni más ni menos que gran parte del mundo
desarrollado y la inmensa mayor parte
del mundo occidental ve a la República
de kosovo como un estado soberano lo que
ha supuesto dejar atada de pies y manos
a Serbia a la hora de actuar contra el
independentismo kosovar ahora bien Estos
tipos son tozudos
[Música]
lejos de Rendirse la aspiración de
Belgrado siempre ha sido es y parece que
seguirá siendo la de recuperar la
soberanía sobre kosovo sea como sea y
sabéis qué Por irrealizable que esto nos
pueda parecer Lo cierto es que esta
postura tiene importantes implicaciones
por ejemplo cada vez que los kosovares
anuncian alguna medida por nimia o tonta
que parezca para promover la desconexión
o desvinculación con el estado serbio de
repente la tensión Se dispara y las
cosas se vuelven a poner calientes una
tensión que se vive con especial
intensidad en esta región que veis en
pantalla la conocida como kosovo del
Norte una zona formada por cuatro
municipios en los que los serbios
étnicos son mayoría y ojo porque un poco
más adelante veremos por qué esta región
resulta clave para entender el conflicto
pero ya os adelanto que hablamos de un
área donde no verás prácticamente nada
que tenga que ver con el kosovo
independiente Porque en estos cuatro
municipios la mayor parte de sus
habitantes no se identifican con la
República de kosovo ni con su gobierno
sino que quieren seguir siendo parte de
Serbia Y cómo responde a este anhelo el
gobierno serbio pues seguro que os lo
imagináis
Serbia se ha declarado protector de los
serbios étnicos que viven en esta región
de la República de kosovo en cierto modo
es algo muy similar al modo de proceder
de Vladimir Putin respecto a las
minorías rusas que hay en los Estados
exoviéticos si piensan que los albaneses
vendrán a organizar la vida en el norte
y sin tener derecho a hacerlo Ni con
arreglo al acuerdo de Bruselas ni
conforme con la voluntad del pueblo me
Temo que eso conducirá a un desastre
Alexander buchich presidente de Serbia
Pues bien Justo a finales de 2022 ya
comienzos de 2023 la tensión volvió a
estallar hasta alcanzar cotas muy
elevadas y para muchos analistas podría
estar gestándose un futuro desastre Y si
puede parecernos inconcebible que las
cosas pudieran salirse de madre en plena
Europa pero visto lo visto en Ucrania ya
no resulta nada fácil hacer este tipo de
aseveraciones si algo ha quedado claro
es que la peor de las pesadillas puede
convertirse en realidad la cuestión es
que es lo que ha puesto de nuevo en el
centro de la atención internacional el
conflicto entre Serbia y kosovo es
factible que vuelva a producirse un
conflicto bélico entre estos dos países
Pues bien hoy vamos a responder a todas
estas preguntas pero antes seguro que
has empezado el año con muchos
propósitos para este 2023 quizás hacer
más ejercicio leer más libros usar menos
redes sociales y a lo mejor también
ponerte más en serio con algún idioma
Como por ejemplo el inglés Pues atentos
porque con speakley Se acabaron las
excusas speedley te ofrece todo lo que
necesitas para reforzar tu inglés
aprenderás nuevo vocabulario practicarás
con ejercicios orales escritos
listenings y hasta incluso tienen una
sección con recomendaciones musicales
Quién dijo que estudiar era aburrido la
metodología de speedling no solo
funciona sino que según estudios ha
demostrado ser cinco veces más rápida
que las metodologías tradicionales por
ejemplo practicando solo 30 minutos al
día podrías tener en cosa de tres cuatro
meses un nivel de conversación sólido no
déjate de excusas y ponte las pilas con
el inglés en 2023 de la mano de speakley
descárgate ya mismo la app la tienes
tanto para Android como para iOS y
Pruébalo totalmente gratis durante 7
días si quieres ir a por la suscripción
anual aprovecha el 60% de descuento para
la comunidad de visualpolitik te dejamos
el link abajo en la descripción y ahora
continuemos
[Música]
cambio de letras
a ver si os contamos que las mayores
tensiones político-militares en años
entre los serbios y los kosovares se han
producido por un cambio en las
matrículas de los coches Cómo os quedáis
pues sabéis que no estamos exagerando en
absoluto ha sido un cambio en los
registros de los vehículos por parte del
gobierno de kosovo lo que ha hecho
estallar de nuevo un duro enfrentamiento
étnico y político entre ambos
territorios o mejor dicho ha sido la
gota que ha vuelto a colmar el vaso
[Música]
comenzó en julio de 2022 el gobierno de
kosovo de la mano de Alvin kurty anunció
un plan para llevar a cabo un cambio que
estaba pendiente Desde hacía más de una
década el fin del registro serbio de
vehículos en la República de kosovo El
plan incluye un plazo para cambiar las
matrículas serbias de los vehículos a
otras propias de kosovo y un calendario
de implementación por fases un
calendario que incluía un periodo
inicial de aviso otro de sanciones y
finalmente la imposición forzosa de las
nuevas matrículas lo que incluía por
ejemplo la prohibición de la circulación
o incluso la confiscación de los
vehículos que no cumpliesen con la regla
y no solo eso también se anunció que los
ciudadanos serbios tendrían que manejar
documentos de entrada y salida a la hora
de acceder o salir de la República de
kosovo
Pues bien como fácilmente os podéis
imaginar estas medidas no sentaron nada
pero que nada bien a los kosovares del
Norte que recordad son mayoritariamente
serbios étnicos que además se sienten
ciudadanos serbios
para muchos el tener que gestionar
documentos para poder salir o entrar de
kosovo equivalía convertirse en
ciudadanos de segunda marginados
señalados y lo mismo sucede con las
nuevas matrículas kosovares ya que para
estos serbios étnicos utilizan sus
coches matrículas de un estado que para
ellos no existe y se creó en contra de
su voluntad es algo inaceptable y sí
puede que a ti te parezca una reacción
exagerada pero os aseguro que en estos
territorios la identidad nacional es
algo que viven con mucha intensidad así
que por supuesto No se iban a quedar
cruzados de brazos fijaos
como respuesta a los grupos serbiocos
hogares levantaron en julio de 2022
barricadas en kosovo del Norte y se
declararon insumisos ante las
autoridades una reacción que obligó a
intervenir a las fuerzas de la otan en
kosovo lascafor que se desplegaron de
nuevo para patrullar las calles y
garantizar la seguridad mientras la
policía kosovar cerraba la frontera
En definitiva que por unas matrículas y
unos cuantos papeles el lío ya estaba
formado de nuevo y claro qué queréis que
os diga no es una situación nada pero
que nada fácil tengas la opinión que
tengas sobre la independencia de kosovo
es relativamente sencillo comprender
desde el punto de vista político social
cultural el enfado de unas personas que
han vivido siempre en esa región y que
no se sienten parte del nuevo estado que
los ha incorporado pero no nos desviemos
[Música]
El caso es que después de muchos dimes y
diretes acuerdos amagos de acuerdos
desacuerdos intervenciones políticas y
llamamientos de la Unión Europea y de
Estados Unidos sabéis al final lo que
ocurrió Pues que en noviembre de 2022 el
gobierno de kosovo dijo que lo de las
matrículas se haría Sí o sí y que el
plan por fase sería implementado entre
ese mes de noviembre y abril del 2023 y
lo que sucedió a continuación en fin
cuestión de tiempo era los servió de
kosovo continúan con las dimisiones
masivas en las instituciones del estado
los policías herbocos hogares que
dimitieron de la policía durante el fin
de semana como parte de una dimisión
masiva junto a parlamentarios alcaldes y
funcionarios de Justicia han continuado
renunciando con los policías entregando
sus armas y esposas por supuesto estos
hechos no han pasado desapercibidos en
Serbia y han visto la oportunidad para
intentar desestabilizar las autoridades
kosovares al menos en el norte de la
autoproclamada república como lo han
hecho pues fijaos el estado de Serbia
dice y nosotros lo decimos que nos
encargaremos de ellos eso son 50 o 60
millones de euros más para nosotros nos
encargaremos de todo Alexander buschitch
presidente de Serbia ya sabéis cosas de
la política ahora Serbia vuelve a tener
funcionarios en kosovo Pero eso no es
todo en la semana siguiente las cosas no
han hecho más que empeorar
después de que los serbios étnicos
empezasen a dimitir de las instituciones
ligadas al Estado de kosovo las
tensiones étnicas a nivel de la calle No
tardaron en surgir 10 de diciembre de
2022 los serbios de kosovo bloquean la
carretera a los principales pasos
fronterizos en el volátil norte estaban
indignados por el arresto de un ex
oficial de policía de etnia Serbia
sospechoso de estar involucrado en
recientes ataques contra policías de
kosovo Y continuamos en diciembre del
2022 los serbios anunciaron que ponían a
su ejército en estado de alerta el nivel
de preparación previo a un conflicto
bélico Pues bien Ahora que todos sabemos
más o menos qué es lo que ha pasado en
estos últimos meses para que kosovo y
Serbia vuelvan a merecerse un vídeo
visualpolitik las preguntas que podemos
hacernos son Realmente Hay posibilidades
de ver otra guerra en Europa en el corto
medio plazo podría seria terminar
atacando a kosovo Qué posibilidades hay
de que estaría un conflicto entre estos
dos países y Qué posibilidades hay de
que termine por no ocurrir Pues bien
descubramoslo
la próxima guerra en Europa
la Guerra de Ucrania ha despertado de
golpe y porrazo a toda Europa de un
dulce sueño en el que había estado
sumergida durante las últimas décadas
creer que otra guerra en el viejo
continente era un escenario
completamente imposible ahora por
supuesto ese sentimiento ha cambiado y
junto con Ucrania probablemente el otro
gran punto caliente de la geopolítica
europea son los balcanes Especialmente
los balcanes occidentales y de hecho
pensar en un nuevo conflicto en esta
región no es algo descabellado ahora
bien Es algo de lo que existe riesgo
inmediato y de ser así de qué tipo de
guerra conflicto estaríamos hablando
Pues bien responder a estas preguntas
con respuestas tajantes sería casi como
pretender adivinar el futuro y ya sabéis
que aquí en visualpolitik no somos muy
fanáticos de las bolas de cristal Pero
lo que sí podemos hacer es contaros
Cuáles son los motivos por los que sí y
por los que no podría terminar
produciéndose un encontronazo militar
entre Serbia y kosovo Y qué sucedería si
algo así llegara a pasar
[Música]
por el lado del silla la posibilidad de
un conflicto militar lo primero que hay
que tener en cuenta es que Serbia lleva
ya muchos años realizando importantes
inversiones en defensa que están
sirviendo para mejorar sus capacidades
militares para que os hagáis una idea el
gasto del año 2018 fue casi el doble que
el de 3 años antes y en 2022 invirtió
unos mil millones de euros tan solo en
Nuevo equipamiento
[Música]
Sí vale mil y pico millones puede
parecer una cantidad pequeña para un
país que tiene a la otan protegiendo a
su gran adversario pero lo que llama la
atención es la tendencia que han
adoptado en los últimos años Serbia está
de compra de armas y a sus vecinos no
les gusta entre 2015 y 2021 el gasto en
defensa de Serbia aumentó un 70% hasta
los 1400 millones de dólares cada año
Rusia y Bielorrusia le han dado 10 1029
Rusia le ha entregado 30 tanques y
vehículos blindados de transporte de
personal y le ha vendido un sistema de
defensa aérea ha comprado drones
blindados chinos helicópteros rusos y un
sistema francés de misiles tierra aire
evidentemente más armas y más tensiones
étnico políticas pueden terminar dando
lugar a una cosa un error de cálculo
errores que en entornos de tanta tensión
pueden producirse por los detalles más
absurdos y ojo porque eso es
precisamente lo que no está faltando un
soldado de kosovo fuera de servicio es
sospechoso adherir a dos ciudadanos
locales serbios la policía dijo que
ambas Víctimas de 11 y 21 años fueron
llevadas al hospital y que sus heridas
no ponían en peligro su vida el
sospechoso tiene 33 años ahora bien
quiere decir esto que es cuestión de
tiempo que se produzca otra guerra entre
Serbia y kosovo pues no Por supuesto que
no para nada pero sí que son hechos que
contribuyen a enquistar las tensiones
étnicas y quién sabe si también pudiera
llegar a desencadenar alguna que otra
pequeña escaramuza militar en zonas
fronterizas ahora bien Por qué decimos o
por qué pensamos que es muy poco
probable que Serbia y kosovo se
conviertan en el escenario de otra
guerra en Europa al menos en el corto
plazo Pues bien tenemos varios motivos
para pensar de esta manera y el primero
es más que evidente la presencia de las
fuerzas de la otan las
Ford
desde el final de la guerra entre
servicos o en 1999 hay estacionados en
este último país unos 4.000 soldados de
la otan unas tropas cuya sola presencia
sirve para disuadir cualquier ataque
serbio a gran escala porque claro al
final si se produjera un intento de
Invasión se estaría atacando no solo a
kosovo sino también a tropas de la otan
con lo que la reacción podría ser
enormemente costosa para Serbia y
creerme nadie en Belgrado quiere volver
a ver imágenes que ya forman parte del
pasado
ahora bien si quieres indicios más
concretos prestad atención a estos
titulares de diciembre 2022 Serbia le
pedirá la otan desplegar al ejército y a
la policía Serbia en kosovo 8 de enero
de 2023 la otan rechaza la petición de
Serbia de desplegar sus tropas en kosovo
pensadlo un momento salvo que se tratase
de una retorcida y extraña estratagema
del gobierno serbio no resulta un poco
extraño pedir permiso a la otan para
desplegar Tus fuerzas en un territorio
que consideras propio si realmente
estuvieras pensando en invadirlo
[Aplausos]
claro desde el punto de vista serbio el
territorio de kosovo están Serbia como
la misma Belgrado con lo que pedir
permiso a la otan para despegar fuerzas
serbias y más aún respetar su negativa
resulta bastante revelador por tanto y a
pesar de todos los titulares que podemos
encontrar no parece nada probable que
los serbios estén siquiera pensando en
enfadar a la otan con salidas de tono en
el campo militar Y eso amigos amigas
resulta clave pero sabéis que esto no es
el único argumento que podemos encontrar
para descartar la invasión Serbia Y es
que veréis hace No mucho en
visualpolitik os hablamos en un vídeo
sobre La peculiar relación que tiene
Serbia con la Unión Europea Sí todavía
no habéis visto lo tenéis también abajo
en la descripción Pues bien básicamente
y resumiéndolo mucho Serbia es uno de
los siete estados que mantienen el
estatus de candidato oficial para
convertirse en miembro de pleno derecho
de la Unión Europea y aunque llevan años
demostrando entre poco y nada que estén
haciendo esfuerzos a la hora de hacer
las reformas que permitan Lo cierto es
que su condición está sobre la mesa una
condición Que conlleva importantes
beneficios
[Música]
gracias a ser considerado un candidato
oficial a entrar en el club europeo
servia goza de importantes ventajas
comerciales y también ayudas económicas
os doy tan solo dos datos más del 60% de
todas las exportaciones y entre el 55 y
el 59% de las importaciones de la
economía Serbia se dirigen o proceden de
la Unión Europea y no solo eso entre el
60 y el 80% de toda la inversión
extranjera directa que ha llegado a
Serbia desde el 2010 también procede de
la Unión Europea
[Música]
ahora bien porque os contamos esto pues
recordáis lo que os decíamos al
principio del vídeo sobre el
reconocimiento de kosovo como estamos
soberano independiente por parte de la
gran mayoría de Estados europeos Pues
precisamente eso Si a Serbia se le
ocurre pasarse de la raya con kosovo
peligraría o incluso se eliminaría su
estatus de candidato a miembro de la
Unión Europea y con ello ya podrían
despedirse de todas las ventajas que
esta condición conlleva
por supuesto también se arriesgarían a
sufrir asfixiantes acciones
internacionales como las que se están
llevando a cabo contra Rusia y podéis
creernos eso en un país tan dependiente
económicamente de la Unión Europea como
lo es Serbia podría resultar simple y
llanamente devastador es algo que ya os
hemos contado la respuesta de occidente
a la invasión rusa de Ucrania está
sirviendo Y seguramente sirva en el
futuro de aviso para que muchos países
con aspiraciones militaristas se lo
piensen dos veces
[Música]
además para colmo de males el único gran
apoyo sin paliativos de Serbia respecto
a kosovo es precisamente Rusia y bueno
digamos que con el desgaste económico y
militar que está sufriendo el país de
Putin van a estar ni Ahora ni durante un
buen tiempo como para tirar cohetes así
que ya lo veis las tensiones étnico
políticas e incluso militares han sido
son y parece que seguirán siendo la
forma de relacionarse entre Serbia y
kosovo pero no parece que la sangre vaya
a llegar al río pero ahora llegas hasta
aquí el turno es para ti crees que
kosovo y Serbia volverán a la guerra en
el futuro Cuál crees que sería la
reacción de la comunidad internacional
llegado el caso actuarían Igual más
activamente o más pasivamente que con
Ucrania déjanos por aquí abajo tus
comentarios y ya sabes si te gustó Este
vídeo No olvides darle a like y
suscribirte a nuestro canal Para no
perderte ninguna novedad una vez más
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]